all right but I'm still going to be just
finish your breakfast probably
okay why don't we go ahead and get
started want to welcome everyone to our
Thursday conference hopefully everyone's
well rested after their Thanksgiving
holiday and I'm also delighted to
introduce this week's speaker who's
someone I've known for a number of years
as a colleague and a friend and a
facebook friend and other things and
laura's had a lot of interaction with
our program over the years some of you
have in a previous job have done
internships with her and I I think
leading to some hires which is always
good thing so Laura crafts keys are
speakers she's currently principal
strategist at the med sis group and
she'll tell us what she's doing she's
worked in health IT for 25 years working
with healthcare organizations nationally
and internationally doing various
technology enabled clinical and business
activities she has a great deal of
expertise in in health information
technology and related areas like
population health information exchange
patient engagement so forth she has two
masters degrees in mha and an MBA from
the University of Minnesota and she
lives in portland and in her spare time
does hot yoga and trail running in
forest park and and so she's going to be
interactive so remember for those of you
who want to say something to press the
button on the microphone in front of you
not not so much for here but for people
who are listening online and in fact for
those people listening online if you
want to send a question that's the usual
thing just send a tweet with the hashtag
de maiz comp diem i seee see nof and
we'll pass it to lure thanks Bill you
guys hear me okay
he's given me not the finger but you're
giving me motion oh alright i'll start
the same things alright so bill virginia
everyone thank you for having me here
today and i am going to give kind of an
overview of healthcare technology and I
call it in the trenches it's really what
it looks like from the community
hospital or the hosta idn healthcare
system just sort of contrast that to
what you might be have experience in
your prior lives or learning from an
academic perspective and I want to keep
it light I want to keep it
conversational so I'll throw up
questions or please ask me questions as
we go as bill said I've been in health
care for about an healthcare IT for
about 25 years and I got into this as I
get into most things in my life I
stumbled into it I was doing my summer
internship at the Hennepin County
Medical Center in Minneapolis and this
is I was in the university Minnesota MHA
program which was basically at the time
a grooming program for hospital CEOs or
CEOs excuse me and they said you're
going to go to Hennepin County Medical
Center for the summer and you're going
to work in the IT shop and my first
response honest to god was they used
computers in healthcare and yet so
that's where I started and it's been a
fun ride ever since and I've done a
whole host of things so if bill said I
have a number of areas that I focused
out of my career but I've worked for
Kaiser Permanente I worked for the state
of Wisconsin I've spent most of my time
in consulting I didn't take a year off
and do a sort of a foray into a software
startup company which just affirmed how
much I loved consulting so lots of
experience to draw from
and presently I work for a small
consulting firm called the Med sis group
and mensis groups has been around for a
long time but they were primarily for
many years a staffing and staff aughh
company really did a lot of that in the
late two thousand really the sort of
early era of the height of the high-tech
years of 2008 to 2011 kind of their
heyday and they've shifted and to do
more consulting but one of the trends in
our industry as a whole and you'll see
this in some of my slides is this sort
of that that frenzy of healthcare
technology has is waning and so health
care system health care organizations
consulting firms etc etc are there
they're buying patterns they're hiring
patterns are adapting to those changes
let's see this is my true test of
Technology here so a couple things
really I'm going to focus on today or
some just to sort of set the stage a
couple of industry trends and then talk
about healthcare IT kind of what I see
in the market as a whole and then
focusing on a couple of areas
particularly around patient engagement
hie and analytics and this picture on
the right is the Robert Wood Johnson
presentation it's actually a very good
report just came out earlier this year I
draw from it in my presentation I draw
from a number of other sources but if
you're looking for something about this
thick to read over Christmas break it
would be that it be the one to kind of
put it in context to what I do because
like what do you do when you're a a
thought leader or you did healthcare IT
strategy right now I'm working on three
projects spanning nine time zones which
is a little bit of a problem for my
sleep patterns I'm working at a large
academic medical system in California
they went out and acquired a community
health care system kind of without
enough due diligence which is kind of
akin to one of us buying a cabin off the
internet it looked great in the pictures
and now they have hired myself and a
host of other people to help them really
untangle the technology everything from
the cabling and the infrastructure which
is obsolete to 800 unboxed win XP
computers they found in a storeroom to
moving from one electronic health record
to the system electronic health record
I'm also actually a mention eight i
think i mentioned i was working i did
some work for the state of wisconsin
early in my career been hired by the
state of wisconsin to help them plan an
electronic health record for the seven
treatment facilities the state of
wisconsin runs for the mentally ill the
developmentally disabled and for some
prisoners that need either mental health
or clinical care so again applying those
skills in a really diverse setting and
then my nights literally and weekends
job is to i'm working with a health care
system in South Africa they're deploying
a zoom care like zoom plus like health
care system in South Africa and they
hope to spread it across other countries
in southern Africa and they've reached
out to us so helping to helping to do eh
our strategy in a very different context
with very different you know sort of
financial constraints different patient
populations etc so it's a lot of fun the
work that I do alright enough of that so
really just three sort of themes that
I'm sure you're all aware of in the big
picture you know the first major force
in healthcare today is this shifting
financial accountability moving from you
know the volume to the value to
population health what this is driving
is really more importance of data
analytics financial modeling data
transparency and new tools for accessing
that information from both the provider
side and from a patient side
and one of the things are going to see
in my slides in general and I look to
use this pointer but I'm sure I'll break
it if I do the correlation between the
demographics of our population and the
use of new technology tools and all of
this basically says that and to no
surprise the Millennials are the ones
that are using online tools to really
understand their the financial cost of
their healthcare and to do cause
shopping or to cost comparison the
second sort of major theme is regulatory
activity but a year ago I started
subscribing to a newsletter called
Politico and they have every morning the
morning health news or something it's
really fascinating but also really
depressing to read this newsletter every
day because it really focuses on all of
the regulatory and the legislative
activity around healthcare IT and I for
a long time I tried to really stay
abreast of it and then I realized it was
kind of like a soup of the day there was
always a new congressman proposing a new
law or new regulation my favorite was
probably this first one which is they
were going to create legislation to fix
the EHR issues that was all the further
they had defined it but nevertheless
they did get their name in the in the
trade rags the representatives bills an
activity you'd probably hurt or some of
these obviously Meaningful Use you've
heard but there are all this just this
ongoing flurry of activity at the at the
legislative and the regulatory level one
hand you know it's great to have the
attention on the other hand I'm
conservative will slow innovation in the
industry
the third sort of high-level trend or
driver of where we are as a as an
economy a healthcare economy and I mean
that both from a delivery standpoint and
from a financial standpoint is one
that's really driven by the individuals
and that's consumerism we're moving to a
place where we want affordable
convenient health care and we're shaping
that and I was thinking about it what if
we all went into the bank first we
schedule appointments then we went into
the bank and then we waited for a while
and then somebody came to us and then we
sat down with them and then they gave us
our hundred bucks I mean that's kind of
how we've you know delivered health care
and in and in large part we continue to
do so if I'm this statistic fascinating
about how much time and how much that
time costs us just arranging for seeking
healthcare in the United States yes just
in terms of not nuts just the seeking
process either literally arranging for
health care or getting health care
delivered to you so maybe seeking and
delivering to be a good better way of
phrasing that nevertheless it's a pretty
expensive equation one of the things
that fascinates me about consumerism is
how the industry is responding and who
in the healthcare industry health care
delivery sector is responding and it's
not necessarily the big healthcare
systems it's a lot of what we're seeing
in terms of response to a drive for
convenience and accessibility is coming
from non-traditional payers in
particular the big health care or see
the drugstore the walgreens and the CVS
I'm not sure if I can do this you know
you told me which button it is but like
i said i'll probably blow it out
but two months ago the New York Times
had a fascinating article around CBS and
what CBS is doing to move away from
being a drugstore to being a health care
service provider really we're again
worth reading if you really geeked out
as much as I do about these types of
things but what we're seeing is a big
shift and we see this in zoom zoom plus
here in the Pacific Northwest is moving
away from the traditional healthcare
model placed on our preferences towards
something that's quicker faster cheaper
and potentially better and important for
us is as the CBS s and the walgreens etc
make this transition or drive this
transition they're doing it in a way
that is technology enabled so they're
partnering with health care systems
which I'll get to in a second and or
their enabling their own drugstores
their own clinics with technology
whether it be epic Greenway health has
been another big one or their own
homegrown system as I was working on
this slide a couple a couple months ago
more maybe a month ago and CBS bought
target all of targets clinics so it went
from six to five is overnight there are
about 1700 urgent care minuteclinic type
entities in the United States and that
number will continue to grow but anybody
who's been around for a long time these
things took off about 10 years ago and
then they sort of dissipated or went
quiet for about four years and now the
prevalence of these has really increased
and I think will continue to increase
and I think that a lot of that is driven
by the Affordable Care Act because we
had to get the incentives a line to get
the care delivery models to to move in
the right direction what I think's
important of our on this slide on is
that the health system affiliations this
is what's different about retail clinics
today then
sort of the first generation the CBS is
the walmarts that art whatever they're
going out and they're seeking
affiliations with big healthcare system
the banner health care systems the
Providence's what that does is from a
technology standpoint allows potential
to share systems to share data and also
it becomes sort of a referral chain
where you go from the minute clinic to a
primary care provider to the acute care
setting up that up that food chain much
more deliberate much more strategic than
it was sort of in the first row so any
questions or comments thus far no
anybody need more pizza okay sir I'm
going to talk a little bit about where
the industry is in terms of that
adoption of health care technology
particularly EHRs I that's kind of the
catch-all bucket although there's a ton
of other solutions and systems out there
and then talk a little bit about patient
engagement analytics and and hie sort of
the you have the ugly stepdaughter or
stepchild of all of healthcare IT I
mentioned this earlier you know we've we
sort of hit that peak of just rampant
shopping for health care systems and EA
EHRs although there will always be an
ongoing sort of cycle of replacement of
technologies I think in my opinion that
really the 2009 2012 era was that the
heyday and this is when a lot of
companies you know if you could spell I
tu tu could be an epic implementer
that's shifting those still skills are
still going to be needed but more
refined skills and different set of
skills and actually at Steve right we
were talking about this a little bit
earlier is that from a physician
standpoint health care systems have had
sort of the doc champions for the EHR
the position champions often
time stepping away from their clinical
practice to help out and then they had
the sea mio we're all sort of that at
political figurehead I do believe there
is a an emergence of a strata in between
that of importantly clinical informatics
asst working on population health
working on you know specific disease
cohorts I'm starting to see that in big
healthcare systems a couple interesting
graphs we want is just the uptick of
hospital EHRs and you think great we're
at seventy-five percent well that's at
least at least a basic EHR you look more
closely at the graph it reflects that
three four percent of health or hospital
systems have a what they call a
comprehensive EHR and this would be sort
of the more fuller functionality both
from a transactional standpoint but also
from a health information exchange or
data exchange standpoint physician side
again the numbers look really good what
what I found interesting about this is
the is the the metrics that are
different so the physician one excuse me
the hospital one is looking at a
comprehensive EHR a basic EHR and then
the seventy-five percent is at least a
basic EHR on the physician one we've got
this serve ambiguous any any EHR at
eighty-two percent so you know I don't
know what really what that means and i
think it's sort of poor analytics if
nothing else and poor statistics and
data representation but but in truth if
you take a look at just the basic EHR
we're at forty-one percent and fifty
percent adoption so it's it's you know
we have a long ways to go and proof of
that is probably my favorite slide in
the whole world this is my this is taken
from a visit i had to a hell
care provider will rename and remain
anonymous in 2013 within getting a foot
x-rayed or something and so it's kind of
bad those 2013 it's also kind of bad
that at the time this health care
organization had spent probably 75
million dollars on their EHR I know
because I did the total cost of
ownership model for this hospital a few
years prior 2006-2007 so they'd actually
been live on the EHR for about six years
i walked in i sit down they give me this
clipboard to fill out they asked for my
name and i right same as above because
it's actually in the upper right hand
corner that's for my date of birth and I
right Satan was above and then they
asked me my allergies on my meds and
when I last had a tetanus shot and at
which of course I had no idea so I just
right in the EHR in HR HR and I give
this all to the radiology tech who is
clearly not humored I don't think it's
better it's like my first time I ever
used this slide in a presentation I
popped it up on the screen I'm not
allowed to swear in here okay I popped
it up on the screen and I looked up
there and I thought [ __ ] that's my
social security number it turned out it
wasn't my social security number with my
mrn but I thought my god they actually
have my social security number on this
printout label all right so i use that
slide to say you know even the most
advanced healthcare organization has a
long ways to go in the actual adoption
and the optimization of their EHR but
there's hope because just last night two
and a half years later I got a letter
from this have same health care system
because I have to go back and get my
foot checked again they've advanced
because not they're not giving me the
clipboard this time they actually mailed
the forms to me to fill help I think you
have got to be kidding me so
anyways but this is just really sort of
endemic in the industry right we just as
advanced as we are we are so entrenched
in our practices but hope springs
eternal because we have all these brand
new technologies how many of you
familiar with this Gartner hype Gartner
hype curve yeah I'm sure you are yes sir
yeah great question well first of all
and the form is unnecessary right
they've just checked me in I could I
could have done this on a kiosk well I
went to the clinic once and the kiosk
was broken but besides that they know my
allergies they know my medications I
should walk in they say hey Laura are
you still allergic to X and Y Z and
that's yet when they see the care
provider and they're going to ask me
these questions anyways when I sit down
they're going to say you know are these
your medications and I'm going to say
yeah the same ones i just wrote on the
forum that you have in the EHR only
they're spelled correctly in the EHR so
i think just this notion that we're
creating extra process or extra work
because that's the way we've always done
it you know this esteemed health care
delivery institution I've filled out a
number that despite the fact that our
records have been an epic for what going
on eight years would we do the same
thing in fact my daughter who's having a
dermatology council got a letter asking
her to fill out all this on paper yes so
it is endemic I just threw the papers
out when I got them last night after
after I blew a gasket and then I do the
papers out so the Gartner hype curve has
been around forever and it really sort
of shows longitudinally sort of the
waxing and waning of healthcare
technologies and it's a little hard to
read but see if you read from left to
right you have this sort of new
innovative technologies and then you go
to this peak of inflated expectations
where it's going to do everything and
then you hit the trough of
disillusionment
I get to the slope of enlightenment and
plateau of productivity somewhere over
here is speech recognition and probably
the EHR but people love this graph
because you know if it's this is how we
have operated as an industry is it's the
next shiny object right so you'll see
prescriptive analytics is kind of on the
way up Big Data cloud computing Yeti
idea my favorite however and see if I
can it's hard to read but this says
software-defined anything and inflicted
somebody just slip that in or is it
actually a technology but it look into
this notion that we're always chasing
sort of the next great thing where we're
not really optimizing or effectively
deploying the technologies we do have so
when you step back and ask the cios of
those sort of the the community
healthcare systems and the ideas what
are their top top priorities they look
very different from that hype curve and
this came from the advisory board
earlier this year visor boards a good
research for many things related to
analytics bi cost before words
management and analytics around that
enterprise integration architecture I
think that's stemming from a lot of
mergers and acquisitions a lot of health
care systems and data that need to be
aligned and better govern but not a lot
of those really sexy things that you saw
over here on the hype curve which
reflects to me that sort of the
difference between where we are going
and where we are at practically
interestingly enough health information
exchange data integration per se isn't
on here I think it's there either so
frustrated with it or they're just
trying CIOs are trying to ignore it
because it's such a painful topic of
conversation typically I'm I'm going to
shift now and dive into a couple of
these just kind of the
yeah go ahead I'm just wondering is this
top ten in the order of importance no
unfortunately okay I couldn't bullet
down security at the bottom is like hmm
yeah no that's a great question a lot of
what I read in here and see is that
security if probably the one one of the
top three concerns within healthcare
systems and its data security and its
network security patient privacy and you
know we'll see that a little bit as we
talk about health information exchange
and that component the privacy data
security is really a challenge it was
really fun actually looking for pictures
for David David Letterman to anybody see
him he's got like right now this great
big white beard she goes through that
like David what happened you know I
think it's more just mobile applications
both from a provider standpoint and from
a that's that's part of it and it's kind
of like kind of blurs between patient
engagement and patient data
contributions and I do think the whole
connected biomedical devices and that
data flow from there is going to be
hugely important going forward so I've
been a fan fascinated by a patient
engagement for a long time and I really
start I really think right at a point
where it's starting to mature or evolve
and we're talking now really more in
partnership oftentimes with our
healthcare providers and provider
organizations a lot of that is around
cost-effectiveness value and ROI it's a
different kind of type of conversation
than we had 10 and 15 years ago who are
those driving has changed obviously the
Millennials are that you know they just
have a different way of conversing
different set of expectations but
interestingly enough those who are
chronically ill who are really poor
health status
they are probably one of the biggest
cohorts actively engaged patients from a
technology standpoint so there I think
that the uptick of their use of tools is
pretty significant the last piece you
know I think that there's a misalignment
or a lack of alignment between what
patients want in terms of Technology
tools and technology for engagement and
what we are positioned to deliver so
from a patient preference or a consumer
preference mobile application research
scorecards self monitoring technologies
you mentioned and really built use of
social media for healthcare reasons but
when we see what healthcare
organizations are delivering in terms of
quote-unquote patient engagement it's a
different story it's a very much static
non-connected solutions this came out
from hims earlier this year we're still
tethered to sort of those traditional
patient engagement products like the
portal and the website uptick and social
media I think that's pretty significant
both in engaging with patients but also
mining patient data the patient
concierge service just seems really sort
of circuit 1800s for me that the last
thing I want is to somebody to manually
point me down just make it easier that's
I mean I don't need much more than an
info booth at best but when I step back
you know I to this flight I still feel
like as an industry we haven't caught up
with patient desires or consumer desires
yet and then finally the health and the
actual engagement that we're doing from
a technology perspective is still really
focused in the the administrator these
numbers are ridiculously hard to see but
off to the left it's basically says
twenty percent of
people who wish to securely message
their providers have done so so that's
basically a 20-percent penetration in
clinical communication off to the right
when we get to online bill pain and
making an appointment the percentage is
thirty-three percent so still very small
percentages but clearly weighted towards
those sort of transactional tasks and
not really value add in getting clinical
care question in the comments nothing um
shifting gears just I mean talking about
healthcare analytics and this is again
from a very practical standpoint you
guys are always smarter than I'll ever
be in terms of clinical informatics and
bioinformatics what we know is that
we're doing a better job than ever of
capturing data the volume is growing
forty percent a year we're doing it
through the EHRs and a host of other
transactional systems patient generated
data etc etc but the big question is you
know what can we do it with it and you
know that's that's your question and
then you know kind of my question is
what are we doing with it and
unfortunately we're not doing much if
you go out to sort of the
bread-and-butter healthcare delivery
systems this is really kind of how we're
using healthcare data and informatics
today and the first four are really
things we've been doing forever right
there's no innovation there the
physician or provider comparative
performance outliers and risk and cost
utilization these are not racket these
are not rocket science activities but
yet these are the ones that were for the
main that I have mainstream adoption
it's not till we get down to the bottom
which have like the 22 and 23 percent
usage rate with comparative
effectiveness impact ability modeling
etc etc are we really using the
information
and the skills that were we're nurturing
so I you know I think if we were to go
back and juxtapose out on the hype curve
you know I ironically here we are in
sort of this we've passed this peak of
inflated expectations or in that trough
of disillusionment with quote unquote
big data because we realize that it's
hard and we're not doing a very good job
of it yet and I a lot of that it has to
do with the skills and the resources
available to do that in your mainstream
health care system even if they had all
of you I'm not sure they know in many
cases what to do with you I think that's
changing I think it's changing and some
of the more innovative in larger health
care systems but it's definitely a
trickle-down process and what I see is
probably the biggest challenge around
data and analytics for the the sort of
traditional health care system is data
governance really understanding and
structuring that data architecture and
aligning it across systems both
technically and politically at working
with a big academic in the bay area
right now that's going to be probably
their biggest challenge is that
enterprise governance around systems and
data as they as they move to exploit
what they have for clinical research
purposes and then that skillset thing
about two years ago I did a sort of a
round table with a bunch of CIOs from
healthcare systems and they were
Adventist and spectrum and it wasn't
Northwestern but another one in Chicago
I advocate about six or seven CIOs and
they all said their biggest concern was
to find the people that had both the
technical and the analytical analytic
and the clinical skills for their
organizations for the next two to three
years
so I love this definition but I did and
I'll tell you not everybody loves this
definition and Bill stevil welcome your
perspectives came from a VPS explore us
a person data scientists is a person who
uses data and infirm at information to
ask the question you should have asked
not the one you did and I think there's
a lot of truth to that right it's
helping us sort of evolve our thinking
you know because if it were left up to
me I'd just hand out cliff clipboards
all the time just kidding but so it
becomes sort of a mindset that you guys
are always thinking about well what well
what does that mean what does that
really mean in my role and because I
focus so much on healthcare IT strategy
they always say I'm always thinking
about what's next I haven't really
thought much about EHRs for 10 years
because I'm always thinking about what's
next and I think from a data scientist
standpoint you know what's the question
behind the question however not
everybody loves this definition I have a
physician colleague who had sort of a
visceral reaction to it it was
interesting he said Lee he felt like it
would it was an offensive definition to
the physician right because it would
offend their clinical expertise don't
tell me what question I should be asking
and I think that maybe more of his own
sort of personal position then maybe the
whole not representative of the whole
physician community but I I also took it
as a note of caution to how clinical
informatics is how we approach sort of
that melding of disciplines
and again back to that same question you
know now that we've got the data what
can we do it what should we be doing
with it you know it's I'm sort of what
can we do with it which was that slide
of archaic reporting you know what can
we do with it is you know your
responsibilities that is informatics
asst finally health information exchange
the ugly stepchild of healthcare IT and
it's fascinating have you guys ever
tried to explain to somebody out of
health care or health care ity to eat
EHRs don't talk to one another I said
it's like we all are using different
dollars and every dollar has a different
basis and people get it like so my
dollars was 98 cents and years is worth
a dollar 04 and they're all in you know
different currencies but so there's
health information exchange the verb
which is the actual transaction and
there's health information the
organization and today or this was
earlier this year based on us you know a
sort of a standard definition there's
about a hundred and six operational
health information exchanges in the
United States again the frenzy of hie is
popping up everywhere based on high-tech
funding that has its dissipating I would
anticipate that within five years half
of these hie s will be gone there's no
get to this moment there's all sorts of
technical and political challenges with
these and i think the capabilities of
healthcare inherent systems to start
exchanging better will mitigate the
needs for these organizations to
basically be hub and spokes so they'll
come back up five years and we'll
revisit the slide the challenge with hie
s in terms of the verb is today we're
basically exchanging pdfs static
documents
so we've got organizations that are
struggling and the information that
they're exchanging is marginally a value
in many cases many cases so sort of
stepping back what are the challenges
health information exchange experiences
from both a noun and a verb standpoint
health if anyone has anybody worked in
or for a health information exchange so
I love your perspective on this the ones
I worked with they spend a lot of time
sort of either navel-gazing or fighting
about semantics in many cases so what
are we what's our governance model who's
going to pay for what who's in the
pecking order but then we get to things
from very legitimate things like privacy
and confidentiality security concerns
what I see from the noun from the health
information exchange perspective there's
really not a lot of technical issues in
their challenges or many times in their
demise probably the last to the patient
Matic matching the consent model can be
the most complex from a process or
procedure standpoint as well as a
technical standpoint conversely on the
verb side the actual exchange of the
information that's where the the
plumbing gets complicated patient
matching and consent model complexity
are very very complicated last what a
year and a half ago I did some work here
in the Pacific Northwest between Kaiser
and Providence and Intel Intel had some
on-site clinics using one EHR and was
doing it and is doing kind of a
risk-based insurance care delivery model
we retail employees will get their care
at the clinics on the Intel campus and
then the will get their secondary
tertiary care at either Kaiser
Providence as we worked through the
mechanics of that the consent model
complexity was probably the most
challenging attribute of the whole
program and you know what data even down
to the data element under what
circumstances get root gets released for
what patient type etc etc so until we
can sort some of that out thats makes
the data exchange and the value of the
data exchange rather marginalized the
rest of these you're familiar with the
data integrity quality and I think the
lack of integration in actual clinical
workflow with the exception of things
like ethics might care everywhere so
many of the times you have to go outside
your clinical workflow to get to any
exchange information or click down into
a PDF buried you know 43 clicks down I
think there's that is troublesome for
hie as we've traditionally known it
God's comments I don't see standards
coming from the federal government
anywhere in the H I challenges or slides
do you think they are a big obstacle and
achieving a che the lack of standards
and I do I think there's increased
standardization a lot of that's been
driven by mu and common data sets thing
and things like sno-med and Lloyd so
we're moving sort of gradually as an
industry towards that very gradually
like you know frozen molasses I also
think we're starting to see a
coalescence of thinking around standard
well I was going to say I mean it's
interesting that the fact that we have
to have hie the noun that we have to
have these organizations I mean even
though we do because otherwise it
wouldn't happen but theoretically if
data were liquid as some people have
called for it to be it should just flow
automatically if you're a health care
provider you know or a patient who wants
your data sent from point A to point B
it should just happen you know rather
than have to go between some kind of hie
organization or entity
do you think there are cases where PDFs
are used to protect market share for
vendors because if you can't actually
have data flow from one system to
another then it's easier to keep the
hospital connected to them
if I have all of my healthcare data I
can go anywhere with it then get care
anywhere it's a lot the analogy would be
you know your phone number portability
once I didn't have to change phone
numbers and changing carriers I could
shop around for carriers so how much of
the of the inertia is maybe not
consciously but subconsciously due to
the entities themselves not wanting
patients to be able to shop around like
once you go to that clinic it's hard for
you to leave because your information
can't leave
yeah and it truly right takes a village
they were technology shin that's right
yeah not going to help him here all
right so I've done a lot of work at
sutter health and one of their main
drivers for an enterprise hie which was
was referrals particularly in lab tests
leakage that was costing them you know
tens of million dollars a year so they
went out and they invested in a hie
product to connect they already have
epic in their eat and their hospitals in
your clinics but to connect sort of that
second secondary level of physicians who
did a lot of referrals to the Sutter
systems so it is all about retention and
let them or and referrals
any other questions or comments on this
no we're at this couple more minutes and
i'll leave it open for bantering
clip was just cute um there was four
five six seven years ago this huge
backlash about you know my my doctor is
going to just think about me as a number
aren't going to stare at the computer
screen you know this was this whole sort
of mechanization of the care process I
think we're working through that because
as individuals as a society as a
healthcare system we're learning to work
with the technology differently so it's
integrating it into the care system Curt
and the care interaction how many have
gone to zoom plus or zoom care yes
favorite health care they just they just
flip the chart and the like okay this is
all your information here's what i'm
typing in is it you know so it's a very
transparent process and you're still
interacting face to face with your
provider so i think five six years ago
the concern was we're going to lose the
person the care and medicine I think
we're maturing our thought around that
thing we're going to make the caring
better in medicine because of Technology
so I think that's it oh I really liked
this slide first the kind of the message
it was around and the y-axis is
incentive to share data outside the
healthcare system and the x-axis is sort
of the level of integration across
within the healthcare organization I
really like this slide and then I went
back and I read what the author wrote
about it and I'll pop it up in the
screen in a second but it essentially
says lower left-hand corner it's sort of
the fee-for-service model lack of
integration and low incentive to share
data it's just about a volume-based
transactional healthcare delivery system
that's kind of what we've lived in and
then we move sort of towards this mid
ground which is but total cost of care
where a single healthcare organization
was to assumed responsibility for
caring for an event and then sort of
that nirvana in the middle is this
bundled episode of care where you're
working across a number of healthcare
entities or providers kind of in the ACO
model where you have both clinical
integration and a need in an incentive
to share information to keep unnecessary
costs down the other really nice graph
the way it's described and it represents
a lot of sort of complex concept and
then i went back and i read this author
who was had a little bit more of an
answer basic approach or tone to his
writing and so he writes or see race
riskless fee-for-service preserves the
medical archipelago and full risk aceo
arrangements turn the archipelago into
Kwazii monopolistic super islands using
landlocked patients to achieve
institutional rents and I thought man
BAM don't mess around but but truly that
what has happened right so you know we
get these sort of ACL my lap
monopolistic super Islands I believe we
will evolve past that sort of with the
data liquidity concept but we're
certainly in the net transitional era
and I wish I could write like that so
that's in that's all I had really from a
slide perspective but I loved it talk
more and more questions great